tu es donc la première loi sans lien
avec le coronavirus être votée par
l'assemblée depuis le déconfinement le
parlement vient d'adopter définitivement
la proposition de la loi de lutte contre
la haine en ligne elle vise à lutter
contre les contenus haineux sur internet
les députés viennent donc de l'adopter
définitivement après un an de navettes
parlementaires un texte loin de faire
l'unanimité
pour plus de précisions nous rejoignons
en direct sur place à notre reporter
neige à dera sach en direct de
l'assemblée nationale bonsoir neige une
loi controversée qui vient donc d'être
adopté
oui définitivement adoptée par
l'assemblée nationale cet après-midi 355
voix pour 150 contre 47 abstentions
alors dans les détails hier la majorité
les députés udi agir ont majoritairement
voté en faveur de ce texte les
socialistes se sont pour la plupart
abstenus alors que les parlementaires de
droite de liberté territoire de la
france en sont mises et du rassemblement
national se sont se sont opposés à cette
loi vous l'avez dit vise à lutter contre
les contenus haineux sur internet avec
nous pour en parler eric ciotti député
les républicains des alpes-maritimes
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous vous avez
voté contre ce texte de loi
pourquoi j'ai voté contre ce texte de
loi parce qu'il me paraît constituer en
recul pour la liberté d'expression dans
notre pays
nous sommes un pays de liberté et cette
liberté nous devons la conserver moi je
refuse que cette liberté soit
aujourd'hui placés dans les mains de
multinationales du numérique amazon
facebook dans lesquels je n'ai aucune
confiance et qui demain peuvent peser
sur le cours démocratique de notre pays
peuvent censuré peut-être
et je l'espère des contenus haineux mais
peuvent aussi censurer des opinions des
expressions politiques et ça c'est une
dérive qui paraît dangereuse bien sûr et
j'avais déposé d'ailleurs une
proposition de loi dans ce sens il faut
lutter combattre contre les propos les
propos et deux sur les réseaux sociaux
sur internet et notamment sur cette
montée de l'antisémitisme mais cela se
doit se faire par le biais judiciaire
cela doit être heureux être imposée très
fortement par des amendes très lourdes
comme l'a fait l'allemagne pour les
fournisseurs d'accès à internet pour les
gaffes à google amazon facebook oui mais
leur laisser une liberté de dire ce qui
est politiquement correct et ce qui ne
l'est pas cela me paraît représenter une
dérive très dangereuse c'est ce qui m'a
conduit à m'opposer à vous opposer à son
ex on va peut-être sur cette polémique
qui entoure laetitia avia depuis
quelques mois puis cette enquête
accablante de mediapart au sujet bien de
ces accusations de cinq anciens
collaborateurs à elle qui l'accusent
d'avoir proféré à plusieurs reprises des
propos racistes homophobes et sexistes
je ne mélange ray pas les deux sujets
moi je ne fais pas de deux procès
personnel
ces attaques arrivons au moment du débat
je crois qu'il y avait suffisamment
d'arguments dans le texte pour parcourir
à des éléments extérieurs sur lesquels
je n'ai aucune capacité d'appréciation
donc j'ai entendu ce qu'a dit madame
aviales allait déposer plainte la
justice dira le dira les choses c'est
pas à moi de de les dire j'aime pas de
façon générale les lynchages médiatiques
merci beaucoup eric ciotti député des
les républicains des alpes-maritimes
d'avoir répondu à nos questions ce soir
sur rtl france donc vous l'avez entendu
eric ciotti bien qu'ils estiment que
cette loi
avia et bien va favoriser la censure sur
internet et va à porter atteinte à la
liberté d'expression une loi qui va
devoir qui va entrer en vigueur le 1er
juillet prochain et razak en direct donc
de l'assemblée nationale